[Music]
what consciousness really holds to be
the truth of the matter is only this
intermediate state of imperfection a
state nevertheless which at least is
supposed to be a progress towards
perfection but it cannot even be that
for it to advance and morality would
really be to move towards its
disappearance that is to say the goal
would be the nothingness or the
abolition mentioned above of morality
and consciousness itself but to approach
ever nearer to nothingness means to
diminish
besides advancing as such like
diminishing would assume quantitative
differences in morality but there can be
no question of these in it in morality
as in consciousness for which the moral
purpose is pure duty there cannot be any
thought at all of difference least of
all of the superficial one of quantity
there's only one virtue only one pure
Duty only one morality
paragraph 623 picks up where the
previous one left us that is in this
problematic dialectic of the development
of morality and what do we mean by
development of morality we're talking
about the moral self-consciousness
attempting to transform itself along
some lines so we're talking about you
could call it an intentional way of
living and it might not actually be all
that intentional in a completely
conscious since one could be responding
to one's culture one's environment
talking about duty you know making
yourself into the kind of person who
will be able to fulfill one's duty and
we'll do it as a matter of course as a
matter of fact that's perhaps a better
way to think about what Hegel's driving
at here than somebody who is devoting
tons and tons of thoughts and
introspection and self scrutiny and
doing journaling and keeping track of
that sort of thing why is that the case
well to talk about this in very broad
terms to sort of jump you know to a high
level of abstraction what this paragraph
is really about what it's really saying
is that in trying to realize morality we
destroy it now why is that the case
we've talked about this already in
previous paragraph so some of what Hegel
is saying here is really recapping so
let's turn to the text now he says what
consciousness really holds to be the
truth the VAR height of the matter is
only this intermediate stage of
imperfection what intermediate stage are
we talking about the stage where we are
doing something we're advancing we're
making you could say
progress and how do we make progress in
perfection we do that precisely by
acting through behavior through
comportment through choices that we make
han dong has been the word and Han lung
has been the other word used over and
over although we could also use taught
the deed right but Han Lang has this
this notion of something iterative
something that we're doing over and over
and over again what we're doing or at
least what we're striving to do is to
move from a point a beginning point of a
lack of perfection towards a greater
perfection and ultimately the pinnacle
of it now we saw in the previous
paragraph that what moral consciousness
is doing is really a game with itself it
doesn't have a clear idea of what this
perfection would be it represents it in
a beyond and it says well you know I'll
never actually get to that beyond but so
long as I'm doing my best so long as I'm
getting as you know the old adage every
day I'm getting better and better and
better that self affirmation thing
people were supposed to say to
themselves looking in the mirror Hegel
saying no that's not going to work at
all it's not going to work in the sense
it's not going to lead you to where you
want to go and he's going to give us two
reasons for that
so he says consciousness focuses on this
intermediate stage of imperfection but
this is at least supposed to be a
progress towards perfection what is a
progress towards perfection it is moving
to one state where you're a bit more
perfect than another state where you're
a bit more perfect another state
hopefully you're not doing any
backsliding because if you do any as we
call it backsliding then you have to
start from the beginning again
or at least wherever
you back sled two you can represent this
to yourself spatially however you like
climbing a mountain you know you slip
down ten feet now you've got to cover
that ten feet again so this is what
Hegel is driving at in examining the way
a lot of people think about their moral
life Hegel says it cannot even be that
why so here's the first reason to
advance in morality would really be to
move towards its disappearance so if
you're making progress and you were
actually able to make progress all the
way to the end there would be no
morality if it was to be realized if it
was to be a vehicle a kite in actuality
it would no longer exist why well this
goes back to what moral consciousness is
struggling with nature its own nature
right moral consciousness is situated in
a human being and that human being has a
nature and that nature includes
inclinations noggin right and drives
Haven right these things that are
perhaps unconscious perhaps less
conscious certainly we could say
appetite we could say desires whatever
you like they seem to be irrational they
have a law of their own and they drive
us in ways that lead us towards what we
conceive of is happiness but away from
our duty so we have to suppress those or
we have to bring them under reason we
have to make them rational we have to
transform them in the process when we've
done that entirely we wind up over here
and then we no longer have to struggle
at all
we have at that point what Kant in his
religion within the limits of reason
alone calls a holy will a will that no
longer has to struggle against
inclination
appetites desires are frail damaged
human nature but automatically chooses
to do the right thing
Will's correctly but if it does that
automatically doing what you would think
would be absolutely right it's no longer
right there's no longer Hegel saying any
moral significance so morality winds up
being destroyed it winds up vanishing in
the very process of trying to realize it
so he says the goal in this case the
goal would turn into the nothingness
were the abolition of morality and then
he says something a little bit more
interesting not only the abolition of
morality the abolition of consciousness
itself now why would consciousness be
gone why wouldn't the person be over
here and just be like a pure duty it's
so wonderful I'm realizing it wow I
don't even have to think about it I just
sort of automatically do my duty this is
so great well in order for there to be
consciousness of duty Duty has to be
opposed to something else and this is
the problematic that Hegel is working
with here so we have another form of
self-deception happening on the part of
the moral consciousness now here's the
second reason he says advancing as such
like diminishing advancing and
diminishing are both quantitative
differences whenever you see Hegel
bringing up this word quantitative
imagine that there's always a bad taste
in your mouth because Hegel thinks that
the quantitative is not particularly
good important essential it's just mere
quantitative difference and it doesn't I
mean this is a kind of a pun right
quantitative differences don't add up to
anything
they are arbitrary they are abstract
they don't produce anything and it's not
like you can quantify more
even though we might come up with
interesting rubrics for it and he says
there can be no question of these named
minimally quantitative differences in it
in genuine advancing so he says in
morality as in consciousness for which
the moral purpose is pure duty
there cannot be any thought of
difference least of all the superficial
one of quantity there is only one virtue
one two guns right only one pure Duty
only one morality it's like an off on
switch it's not like a dimmer switch
either you're gonna fulfill what virtue
requires what Duty requires what
morality requires or you're not and if
you say well I got halfway there yeah
well you didn't get any of the way there
if you getting halfway doesn't mean
anything more than getting one-third of
the way or you know ticking off seven of
the boxes of the ten either you do the
whole thing or you don't
that's what Hegel saying here about
morality as understood by consciousness
so we have an impasse here and now we
have to see where this impasse is going
to lead us
since then it is not moral perfection
that is taken seriously but rather the
intermediate state that is as just
argued naam morality with us returned
from another aspect to the content of
the first postulate that is we cannot
understand how happiness is to be
demanded for this moral consciousness on
the ground of its worthiness it is aware
of its imperfection and cannot therefore
in point of fact a man happiness as a
dessert as something of which it is
worthy it can only ask for happiness to
be granted as a free act of grace that
is it can only ask for happiness as such
as something existing in and for itself
and can expect it not on the absolute
ground mention above but as coming to it
by chance and Caprice here that non
morality declares just what it is that
it is concerned not about morality but
solely about happiness as such without
reference to morality
now in paragraph 624 Hegel is going to
reintroduce the consideration of
happiness something that he has been
talking about quite a bit throughout the
entire phenomenology particularly in the
reason and the spirit section and in
relation to morality we've talked about
the postulation of a harmony between
happiness and morality and we talked
about how that would actually take place
here there's no postulating that we've
already left that a bit behind instead
what we have is a disjunction between
morality and happiness and happiness is
going to be revealed as taking the place
of morality and why is this important
well remember what this entire section
is about for Stalin which is dissembling
or duplicity moral consciousness
deceiving itself and it really in effect
deceiving other people and what it's
saying about its own motives and its own
process so he says it's not moral
perfection that's taken seriously why
because if we realize morality we would
destroy it and because you know you
can't actually get there by a bunch of
steps and because it's off in this
beyond that makes it you know solely
ideal this perfection of morality just
is not possible at this stage she says
it's not moral perfection that's taken
seriously
instead it's this intermediate stage
this process of progress towards
something that's never realized and that
has been now valorized for its own sake
by moral consciousness so that it can it
can in effect lie to itself and say I'm
a good guy because at least I'm trying
at least I'm making some progress even
though I'll never reach the end at least
I'm on the right track and now this is
something worth thinking about I'm gonna
diverge a little bit from the text when
you say some
like that like I'm making progress
towards this ideal and because I'm
actually making progress in measurable
ways along that path how do you know
you're actually going in the right
direction if you could never realize
that ideal can't even truly cog NIH's it
is haggled said in you know several
paragraphs earlier how do you know
you're going in that direction and
that's something worth thinking about
I'm gonna leave that aside for right now
because he's not actually worried at
this point he's got a different issue
that he's going to bring up so he says
because it's this intermediate state
what is this intermediate state well if
we want to be quite clear about it you
could call it moral progress but it's
really because it's just moral progress
non morality it's it's not moral if I'm
struggling with my desires and
inclinations and repressing them or
rationalizing them in some way just so I
can actually do the right thing that I'm
not really inclined to do I am in some
sense acting morally but in another
sense I'm not acting morally at all
because to be moral would be to have the
right inclination wouldn't it have the
right desires so he goes on and he says
we return from another aspect to the
content of the first postulate what was
the first postulate had to do with
happiness the harmony the integration
between happiness and morality I'm a
good boy I do the right things so I'm
going to be rewarded with happiness but
now notice what Hegel says here I can't
be moral I can't ever realize this even
though I'm making progress even though
I'm striving even though my actions and
motivations are oriented and what I
think to be the right way so why do I
deserve happiness at all why does
happiness enter into the picture
you could say well you know if you don't
get enough happiness you can't sustain
yourself along the way but maybe this
desire for happiness is what keeps me
from being moral isn't it maybe giving
me a little bit of happiness to secure
me along the path is actually leading me
away from the path or we don't really
know maybe I'm only on the path to get
those little bits of happiness along the
way maybe I've got the wrong motivation
maybe I'm learning the wrong lesson by
getting this little pill of happiness at
each point so he says we cannot
understand how happiness is to be
demanded for this moral consciousness on
a particular ground
what would the particular ground be its
worthiness it doesn't have any moral
now.you it's not worthy of enjoying
happiness if anybody is worthy of
enjoying happiness it's a person who
does his duty because he recognizes it
as his duty and doesn't seek his own
happiness then the happiness is like a
reward that you get afterwards but you
could actually say well that's the wrong
person to give it to because what the
hell does he care he's already done his
duty
adding happiness to it isn't gonna make
him any better here's here's a place by
the way where various day ontological
theories really do in fact differ from
each other where the conch in way is
radically different from say the natural
law of Thomas Aquinas way or the stoic
way where Duty is to be done but it's
going to lead to happiness for us right
for cognitive happiness enters in as a
motive at all you've already screwed it
up it's not moral so I can't deserve
happiness if I'm this person here or
even the person who's making constant
moral progress
I don't deserve happiness can I have
happiness is it possible for me to enjoy
it well sure of course it is because
happiness is the satisfaction of your
inclinations and desires or however else
you want to figure it so he says this
consciousness is aware of its
imperfection so it can't demand
happiness as a dessert something of
which it is worthy but it can notice of
the word that he uses here it can ask
for happiness as such as something
existing in and for itself happiness
does exist people do enjoy happiness we
enjoy whatever a portion of happiness we
do have it is happiness right glue a
kite we do enjoy that we are glue click
every once in a while but it's not
something we deserve so how do we get it
when does anybody give it to us he says
it can only ask for happiness to be
granted as a free act of grace that is
it can only ask for happiness as such as
something existing in and for itself not
something that is intrinsic to our
nature not something that we deserve not
something that's actually integrated to
our life if we do enjoy happiness on
this process of progress it just sort of
happens to us I mean it's happiness that
happens right the the anglo-saxon route
to this captures us a bit better than
Hegel's German does half happenstance
happiness right and it means fortune
we're fortunate we are blessed there's
another way of thinking about it and
we're not blessed through our own work
or our own disposition we're just lucky
bastards who happen to have been
fortunate enough to enjoy that happiness
that whatever intelligence or even not
intelligence out there is doling out had
it had us in the lucky crosshairs just
like somebody who's in the crowd when
they're shooting the t-shirt cannon at
the concert right well if you're in the
right place at the right time you get
happiness or not if you're not in the
right place at the right time the
universe says screw you you don't get
any happiness or you get the wrong kind
yeah this is a bit of a digression
Aristotle in talking about friendship he
talks about you know we should give our
friends what it is that they actually
want and what's good for them because
when you give somebody something they
don't want he says
that's almost worse than not giving them
something at all what meaning give them
something they don't want in place of
what it is that they actually want so if
what they really want is for you to you
know tell them what a cool guy they are
then giving them candy or you know
inviting them to a party or you know
giving them a great book they don't care
what they want is you to kiss up to them
and say oh you're so cool you know what
great sunglasses or you know whatever it
is that you think is cool about them you
can say the same thing about happiness
if I give you what counts as happiness
for me you might not be happy at all so
we have to be fortunate in the universe
lining up with us and smacking into the
thing that's actually going to make us
happy I mean I'll give you an example
for myself I like looking out of our
window at you know in the early morning
when when the Sun is starting to rise
and and also at night we have a
beautiful view out of the one window we
have in our apartment you might look at
that and be like that doesn't do
anything for me I'd rather have a pie we
rather be watching a show or I'd rather
be rock climbing and you know I don't
want a rock climb I do I like pie I like
shows but I don't want a rock climb
happiness is something that we wind up
blundering into so he says that we have
a free act of grace and he says we can
expect it not on the absolute ground
mentioned above what is the absolute
ground deserving happiness but as coming
to it by chance
and Caprice Ville Kurt arbitrary right
if somebody wants to give it to us then
we get it so he finishes up here by
saying non morality declares just what
it is that it is concerned not about
morality it's not actually making
progress towards morality it's actually
concerned about happiness without
reference to morality so we don't have a
unification let alone a harmonization or
integration of morality and happiness
instead we have a deterring we're a
moral consciousness in its progress is
really aiming after its own happiness
and it is not moral but it is actual
you